Okay, so here we are, back at the code. For now, what
I will do is, continue to draw the square, but I will comment
the rest of the code out. So, let me go ahead and do
that. Let me quickly save, and run to make sure everything's running well.
All right, the program still seems to be drawing a
square, which is good. Now, if you remember the original challenge,
It was to draw a circle, out of squares. And thus
far, all you've done is just draw, just the one square.
So, given that, here's a question for you. How would you've
build on the code that we've written thus far, to draw
this image. Now, don't worry about writing code right now. All
I want you to do, is identify in plain simple English,
the steps you would take to solve this problem. You can submit your answers on
the discussion forum. Once you're done, make
sure you check this box before you continue.